[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vendredi soir nous allons recevoir
plusieurs groupes sur la place philippe
prévôt ainsi qu'un ensemble de brasseurs
donc c'est des brasseries locales qui
vont se déplacer je tiens à remercier
ses artisans vous permettent vont offrir
un ensemble de deux saveurs de
dégustation pour nos papilles il a fait
de masse et la saint-patrick le vendredi
soir et au vu des différents événements
qui ont eu lieu on a décidé d'orienter
cette fête de manière solidaire et 2 et
ainsi permet de récolter des dons
collectés des affaires des objets du
matériel médical à destination de
l'ukraine
[Musique]
on a aussi le week-end le samedi
dimanche le salon du vin et de la
gourmandise donc là vous pourrez trouver
un ensemble de stands pour justement
apprécié beaucoup de choses et de salle
il y aura bien entendu une urne toujours
à destination de l'ukraine
[Musique]
c'est une place qui permet de fédérer un
ensemble de personnes ou d'activités
aussi et surtout
philippe prévôt c'était le président des
comédiens de la tour c'est une
association qui aide depuis des dizaines
d'années sur triel et y organise des
spectacles de théâtre de manière
régulière donc c'était parfaitement
adaptés finalement d'avoir un espace une
place du monde culturel avec une
personne qui a dédié toute sa vie à la
culture
[Musique]